hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 2
video it's like part 2 of the pilot you
think you get the sense that they made
this TV movie that's 2 hours long even
though there's 16 episodes so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there is a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway that's going
on now all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so top five WTF starting with
number five team Waverider vs. black
market arms sale so much fun here and
you get the sense from the team that
they've forgiven rip hunter at the end
of the last episode they're all just
like WTF dude why did you lie to us why
did you have to tell us that nobody
gives a [ __ ] about us in the future so
they jumped over that hurdle and Captain
cold takes charge like these aren't our
people but we're going into a meeting
with a whole bunch of criminals and
that's what we do
so naturally Captain kolba take charge
international time traveling man of
mystery he can also read foreign
languages to that the rest of the team
can't like I said give me that already
that heatwave calls damian darhk-- a
nazi who is also there remember he's
really long lived has access to waters
from the Lazarus Pit who is very pissed
to not know who Martin Stein and his
crew are I know everybody and I don't
know you who the hell are you he is kind
of dressed in one of those Kim Jong Il's
dictator outfits
Martin Stein's mouth gets them into
trouble which is just the beginning of
the episode his mouth just keeps running
through this entire episode it's a big
episode for Martin Stein like a big arc
for him coming to terms with who he is
also for Captain Cold
hawkman and hawkgirl they had the
biggest arcs in the episode but this
opening scene is just as great action
sequence the atom just immediately
miniaturizes and tries to jump into the
warhead but in doing so leaves behind
tech for Vandal Savage to find and try
and reverse engineer so number 4 WTF
Vandal Savage gets his hands on future
tech and they show the future this
post-apocalyptic central city based on
what happened so depressing but it
serves as an explainer for how time
travel works so they accidentally derp
in the past Vandal Savage uses the tech
to create a dangerous weapon to change
the future but it takes a while for it
to set in stone you pour concrete it
takes a little while to set and they
also explain its kind of getting into
Flash territory now with time travel
explainers that if they were to go back
to an event that they participated in
there'd be a paradox time would fold in
on itself which
exactly what happened on the flash this
week but it makes me think about Barry's
mother's murder like Barry going back in
interacting with the past itself who was
also back with his child self way back
in the background I can hear some of you
guys whispering flashpoint paradox
probably the coolest moment to come out
of that opening scene though aside from
all the great jokes was firestorm
unlocking a new ability being able to
absorb nuclear blast so you'll see him
do that more and more across the series
like learn to unlock new abilities based
on stuff that Martin Stein explains
scientific principles one of the big
things we haven't seen yet is
transmutation we haven't seen firestorm
turn objects into other objects so I'm
looking forward to that on a number
three WTF fixing ray Palmer's dirt they
have to go meet young Martin Stein at
age 25 at Ivy University big location
from the comics the Ronnie Raymond
firestorm in the comics is a student at
Ivy University his professor is Ray
Palmer who on the TV show was the
student of Martin Stein let's smoke if
he Adam I guess it's the 70s so we got a
bunch of weed jokes which is kind of
funny but I do like white canary
flirting with him and him flirting back
I wasn't flirting with you you were
flirting with me really the best comedy
in my mind is just watching Martin Stein
argue with his younger self I did just
start young at each other it's all about
him coming to terms with the idea that
he's been an [ __ ] for the last 40
years and even though Jax is meant to be
the jock character like the character
that doesn't know anything about science
he's the big call to action for Martin
Stein so I'm really liking those two
characters together just like on the
other side of things number 2 double yep
breaking into vandal savage's house for
Captain Cold
and Adam scenes very awesome moments
then talking about how things might have
been you know like if their life had
taken a different path one of my
favorite moments in the episode you
could have been an electrical engineer
in another life I'm a survivor
one day you'll wish you were too very
ominous but there's a lot to unpack from
that scene one I do think that we'll
eventually see an earth 2 version of
Captain Cold I'm hoping they do citizen
cold from the flashpoint storyline where
it's like a good version of Captain Cold
that's an upstanding member of the
community and you get Ray Palmer who's
kind of like a Boy Scout that just
rushes in like oh I know this alarm
system my parents had one just like this
[ __ ] it's a dummy he's probably gonna
find himself in a situation when he's
gonna have to do something that isn't
super noble in order to survive he
all these different hero and villain
characters together if they spend enough
time in close enough proximity their
personalities will start to bleed into
one another so crazy heatwave will
balance out a little bit and the really
lawful good Ray Palmer will swing a
little more neutral thanks to Captain
colds influence but no surprise here
moving on to number one WTF Vandal
Savage is able to kill Hawkman absorb
his essence when they make away with
Hawkgirl before he can kill her
so it's this big call to action for
hawkgirl's character I wasn't feeling a
lot of their scenes in episodes 1 & 2 I
feel like this is the right thing to do
and the producers did confirm that that
was their intention all along like from
a story perspective this was the right
thing to do and because as a time-travel
show Hawkman is not off the show
indefinitely he's listed on IMDB in all
16 episodes but they said that the way
that we will continue to see Hawkman
will conform to the logic that they
presented like they can't go back and
save Carter so if we see him again it
will be a Carter from a different time
period I'm gonna think of him as the
Kenny of the show now you killed Hawkman
you bastard but I think they did a
really good job of ending this episode
on a bookend moment for the first
episode because it's meant to be this
two-hour pilot so it's almost like a TV
movie you could air on its own I'm
wondering if they plotted this out
before the series had been picked up for
16 episodes like they wrote this and
they're like okay we'll do this two-hour
episode if it doesn't get picked up
we'll just air does this movie it'll be
this fun thing all by itself but it got
picked up so they T up the next episode
at the end episode 3 is gonna be
something of a bank heist so I think
time-traveling Ocean's eleven and it's
not necessarily an easter egg but there
was this line captain cold hat at the
end that made me hallucinate zoom
Berry's dad likes to fish a lot
zoom also likes to fish with bait that
moment cut to captain cold saying do we
fish or cut bait so it's not necessarily
connected but when all three of the
writers rooms like legends of tomorrow
arrow and flash all share the same
hallway in their writers rooms so you
could like literally walk out the door
from the flash TV show like the writers
could and walk right into arrow or
legends of tomorrow so now more than
ever I think it's really fun to listen
to very similar sounding dialogue
between characters just a fun game to
play I don't think what
captain cold said had anything to do
with who zoom is but because all of
these shows exist in the same universe I
feel like some of this is intentional so
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and how do you think that we're gonna
see Hawkman next are we gonna see him in
a flashback are we gonna see him alive
but it's gonna be an earlier version of
Hawkman from before he found Hawkgirl
again a really good example of them
running into a past version of Hawkman
would be the Jonah Hex episode when they
go to the Wild West I know everybody's
really pumped about Jonah Hex
but the really big news is the Stephen
Amell just confirmed that we're gonna
see in episode 6 we're gonna see an old
version of Oliver Queen and Connor Hawke
but the really cool thing is that old
Oliver Queen will only have one arm like
he did in Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns hi recently announced news I'm
going to be appearing on an episode 106
of Legends with the goatee one arm and
we're gonna meet connor hawke the lesson
has always Never Say Never
I don't know necessarily that they're
doing a Dark Knight Returns version of
the character it's just that he will
have one arm so there'll be some Easter
eggs for Dark Knight Returns though
congratulations to this week's reverse
flash ring giveaway winner Stephen
Baskerville be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel for
contact details because I started the
new round of the giveaway in this
episode I'll just announce the winner
for that whenever I post my next DC
video it was a little bit of new Wonder
Woman footage but I might do some
Suicide Squad Batman V Superman related
things this weekend so look out for that
there also be some Game of Thrones
tomorrow - I'm really diggin legends as
tomorrow so far but I think it's gonna
be a while before we find out about
season 2 while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for the
Deadpool teaser video that I've just
posted funny montage of characters
getting hit in the nuts and you can
click here for this week's arrow and
flash episodes thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight